and by the way
I'm going out tonight
I just believe I'm still Bejeweled when
I walk in the room I can still make the
whole place Taylor Swift's midnight era
continues with the debut of the video
for the track Bejeweled and it's a total
fairy tale with a Cinderella Story twist
I love it today's evil stepmother
oscar-winning actress Laura Dern how'd
you get in touch with Laura Dern it's
like Oscar winner Laura Dern yes hello
yeah
um I've read I've I've written um a
script it's a one scene script in which
you are going to call me a tired tacky
wench and she's like I'm in and she was
like I'm down
speak not tired tacky wench clean oh
ladies worry not even if she were
allowed to go when she is not the prince
would never have anything to do with
that little Harlot again he tired of her
quite quickly didn't he or should I say
swiftly
she's the coolest she's so funny she's
another one I'm like I'm like friend yes
how do you are my friend now speaking of
friends Tay had her besties the sisters
of Heim take on the roles of her evil
stepsisters well we all know who's not
coming tonight that weasel down there
cleaning up my sick from last night you
must clean my bed pot net we honestly
have to do this entire verbal abuse
thing every time you leave the house
shut up wench as the video goes on Dina
Von Teese plays the singer's fairy
goddess and her longtime collaborator
Jack Antonoff plays her prince but it's
the Easter eggs that have the swifties
talking this one you're saying but I'll
let you say again this has maybe the
most Easter eggs a psychotic amount
it is like we have a PDF file for the
for the Easter eggs in this video yes
because there are so many that that we
could not keep track yeah there are so
many the biggest being hints Tay's next
re-release will be speak now baby love I
think I've been a little too
kind first as Laura speaking violin
strings Play Enchanted in the background
a song off speak now well I'll be
poisoning all the other maidens in the
village
then the Grammy winners seen hitting the
elevator button to the third floor it's
purple like her gown on the Speak Now
cover and her third album familiarity
[Music]
and notice the 13 is also the same color
the re-recording would make it her 13th
album plus it's tased lucky number I'm
smart and I'm hardworking another nod
the clock set to three at the balls
talent show
[Music]
awesome and finally the dragons at the
end of the video hints at one of the
tracks off speak now long live
[Music]
fighting dragons
[Music]
[Applause]